Poi tethers. They come in a bewildering
array of materials, sizes, lengths, and
colors. Trying to sort through all the
options out there can be a little
overwhelming, and it does leave one with
the uncomfortable question of whether
changing up your tethers might improve
your flow. Like, are my tethers holding
me back from that new trick I want to
learn? Are my tethers keeping me from
progressing in my skills? I see people
online doing amazing tricks with fancy
tethers. if I want to spin like them, do
I need the same equipment? So, I am
going to do that thing you're not
supposed to do on YouTube and give you
the answer up front, and that is
probably not. But it is worth asking why
these questions come up in the first
place. Why might you choose one tether
option over another? And what cases are
there where the tether actually does
make a difference?
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video I'm going to
talk a bunch about tethers, the good,
the bad, and how big an impact they
actually make on your spinning. But
before we dive in, I just want to give a
quick shout out to the friends of the
channel. Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire
Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys, Parot Light
Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible. You
can learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. And special
thanks to the non-B business friend of
the channel, Pekka Becklanin. Thank you
so very much for supporting my channel,
my work, and my mission. So, I'm going
to start this off with what may be a
controversial
position.
Tethers are an important component of a
set of
poi. I mean, obviously, we only have
three components, a head, a tether, and
a handle. You don't remove any single
part of that equation and still have a
usable PO. But I think tethers occupy a
really special niche in PO components
because in a lot of ways, they're
probably the most easily interchangeable
and modular part of the prop. And I
think that there are three major areas
of concern with tethers that are
important to consider in purchasing POI
that I'd like to discuss here. Material,
thickness, and length. And yes, those of
you with dirty minds, this video is just
going to go downhill from here. So,
let's start with material.
Many sets of poi, especially contact
poi, are constructed explicitly to be
able to swap out for different tethers
if the desire takes you. And many
companies offer several different
options for PO tethers, both at purchase
or as add-ons to take advantage of those
capabilities. Over the years, I've used
sets of poi with tethers made from coal
cord, nylon strings, flow cord, bondage
rope, static rope, technora, FPC, and
heck, plain old fashioned fabric, too.
Why the bewildering array of materials?
Well, because aside from the handle,
this is the part of the poi that we
interact with the most. It's the part of
the poi that takes the most abuse and
wear and whose feel has the biggest
impact on our spinning experience. To
say nothing of the aesthetic value of
the tether by total size, it is the
biggest and sometimes most visible
component of a set of poi. While back in
the 2000s, it was fashionable to spin
using tether materials that stretched,
this has largely fallen out of fashion
in modern poi. Tether options like coal
cord and flow cord were good fits for a
time when most people spun with
fingerloop handles and didn't perform a
lot of throws, contact moves, or stalls.
But most sets of poi you can purchase
currently will utilize some form of rope
as their tethers with a couple notable
exceptions we'll get into a little
later. And ropes can come with a few
drawbacks. Many kinds of rope were not
created for the specific application of
being po tethers in mind. And as a
result, they can be kind of abrasive to
our hands and break down over time in a
process called pilling. This involves
the rope gradually becoming stiffer and
shorter over time when subjected to the
heavy wear and tear associated with
having a person spin the rope around.
And unfortunately, that's kind of baked
into PO. Now, there are popular options
out there that resist this kind of
pilling, like the smithy rope champion
by Lanternmith, HPC, or its specialty
twin FPC, which is available through
Flow Toys. In each case, these are ropes
that manage the difficult bounds of
being easy on the hands and fingers
while resisting the abrasion process
that leads to pilling. And I'll be real
with you, there's no bad answer here.
All of these rope options will cover the
most important bases and will be with
you for a good long time. If you don't
know why you need a specific rope
option, then you probably really don't
need it. So, what are the exceptions to
this rule? If you've bought a cheap set
of poi off Amazon like these, the
tethers are made with a nylon string
that does not have enough mass to handle
in a stable fashion, and worse, will
shred the skin on your fingers if you
try to wrap them up. Unless you simply
cannot afford to buy a set with better
tethers, avoid these. Spinning with them
will not be fun. And the other is that
if you're expecting to do a lot of po
juggling, then static rope really is the
industry standard at this point. It's
stiff in a way that makes throws and
catches more stable and aesthetically
pleasing. But also bear in mind that
when it comes to learning basic po
tricks, they don't make any significant
difference at all. It's totally fine to
wait to spring for them when you're
deeper into your flow journey and you've
gotten to a point where you really need
them. I also haven't really talked about
sock or fabric poi here yet, and they do
warrant discussion. I personally adore
fabric poi because they are super
visible on video and are incredibly kind
to my hands for their entire length.
With sock or fabric poi though, contact
po tricks really aren't possible. So
this is a pretty specific choice for
those with a more classic po style. If
that's up your alley, I highly recommend
these. And finally, if you're working
with Firepo, then the conversation
really begins and ends with Technora,
which is a type of Aramid like Kevlar
that's been woven into a rope form
factor. And conveniently, all fire prop
manufacturers that I'm aware of produce
their Fire Po with it. It's the 2020s.
Is there actually anybody spinning firep
with chains anymore? Now, there's going
to be no shortage of people that will go
overboard on this or that benefit of
this particular type of rope or that
particular type of rope. Seriously,
dudes will geek out over rope like
they're parts of a car engine or obscure
comic book characters. If you're just
starting out, you will never notice a
difference between most of these
options. Go with what's easily
accessible and focus on what actually
matters here. Practice time. Okay, so
now let's talk a little bit about rope
thickness.
Just like with rope material, this is a
hotly contested question where you will
have people ready to die on their
particular hill of choice. So, let's see
if we can cut through some of the noise
and get some signal. By and large, ropes
tend to be available at a variety of
different thicknesses, ranging from 8 mm
to 10 mm, half an inch, or up to a full
inch in diameter. So, how much of a
difference does that thickness actually
make? Again, it depends on what you're
trying to do with them. Thicker tethers
are generally a better fit for throws.
Having more mass in the tether makes a
poise trajectory through the air a lot
more stable and predictable, but that
same mass can be a problem when you're
just starting out and lead to fatigue
while spinning them for a while.
Personally, I find spinning tethers a/2
in or more wide feels kind of like
spinning baseball bats. And I personally
feel like I have to fight the poi more
than flow with them. Thinner tethers,
like 8 mm or below, on the other hand,
can feel so light that at times they can
feel really difficult to control,
especially when working with contact
moves. I find tethers this thin can feel
wild and unpredictable. They are much
lighter for smaller bodies or sensitive
shoulders, however, so it's a trade-off.
When it comes to learning, I think that
it's helpful to have at least a bit of
mass in the tether because it'll be
really helpful for playing control.
Really thin tethers with less mass will
be more difficult to control. But there
is a break even point where the tether
is so thick that it interferes with your
control by being too massive. In
general, I'm going to say that if your
tethers are between 8 to 10 mm thick,
you're probably doing just fine. You've
got enough mass to work with contact or
throws if you'd like and they're light
enough that you're not fighting with
them as you spin. And once again,
there's the question of sock or fabric
poi. And here I'll say that they feel
great for classic PO styles. Throws are
possible and they do just fine with
those, but contact really isn't
happening. There is one cool thing about
sock or fabric poi here that I want to
single out. And that's that one of the
reasons to have thicker tethers is that
they stand out better on video. Sock po
kind of avoid that question entirely
because they're thick enough their
entire length to show up loud and clear.
If you want the visibility of thicker
tethers without the weight of them, sock
poi are definitely the way to go. All
right, so last consideration. What about
tether
length? This is again a hotly contested
question and we've been through multiple
cycles of it being fashionable to keep
tether short versus having really long
ones. In general, tethers that are at or
around elbow length are good for late
2000s tech poy and rapid stalls. plane
brakes and inversion work. Tethers that
can reach the ground from standing are
better for throws and contact work. They
also tend to make moves that eat up a
lot of volume, like windmills and
flowers, present in a much better
fashion for your audience. Each length
also has its own drawbacks, too. Shorter
PO are more difficult to control. With
less angular momentum holding the poi in
plane, their movements are more
unpredictable, and you need more fine
plane control to ensure they go where
you want them to. In addition, you need
poi that can at least stretch from your
thumb joint to your mid biceps to make
contact po tricks work at all. Longer
poi, on the other hand, require a lot
more effort to move. They just simply
have more mass in them in general. In
addition, inversion work is impossible
without shortening them, and they're not
as responsive to rapid changes in
momentum or tempo. Because my personal
style is so heavily based in dance, I
avoid longer tethers because they just
simply aren't responsive enough to keep
up with me. I find I'm constantly
fighting to stay at tempo and the poi
always feels sluggish to me. If you're
just starting out, the length I always
recommend people start with is that
their poise stretch from their thumb
joint to their shoulder joint. This is a
good all-around length that doesn't make
anything offlimits, nor does it present
any unique challenges. If you don't know
what length is right for you, this is
the one to work with. One thing I really
want to get across, whether we're
talking about material thickness or
length, is that while there are a lot of
options out there, the differences
between them don't actually tend to make
a huge difference if you're just
starting out. You need to get a ways
into your flow journey and figure out
what style of spinning most interests
you and the tricks you most want to
pursue. To really know when and to what
you want to change out your tethers to
in general, if you're wondering whether
it would help to change your tethers,
the answer is actually probably not. The
real answer almost certainly is going to
be more practice. But if there are
specific things you're wrestling with,
here are ways that changing the tethers
could help. Are you struggling with your
planes or finding yourself getting out
of plane as you're working on learning
new tricks? Thicker and longer tethers
might help because the extra mass will
preserve more angular
momentum. Are your contact rolls or
throws wild and all over the place?
Again, thicker or longer tethers might
help give the po more consistent
momentum. Do your fingers keep getting
shredded, or do you find that you're
tearing off your calluses after long
hours of practicing? Maybe switch to
smithy rope, FPC, or sock
po? Do you find your poi to be unwieldy?
Do you have to fight them to keep them
moving, or do they hit the ground too
much? Might be a good idea to switch to
shorter or thinner tethers. Do your
tethers turn into a tangled mess anytime
you try to practice your tricks? Get
thicker
tethers. But also remember that the
tools you use only have so much power to
improve your spinning. Most of the
problems you encounter will be fixed
with practice, not buying something
shiny and new. Changing out your tethers
is only as useful as the degree to which
the feel of your tethers makes you enjoy
the experience of practicing. Regardless
of what tethers you use to do it, work
hard and you will see improvement. Were
there any questions you had about
tethers that I didn't answer in this
video? Please leave me a comment and let
me know what they were. Also, be sure to
like, comment, share, and subscribe to
help other people find this video and to
help my channel grow. Thank you.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I want to give a shout out
to my FL patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much
for your support. You rock. If you'd
like to support the channel, here are
three ways to do it. If you'd like to
get your name in the credits or access
to any of a host of other rewards, you
can hit up my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo and sign up.
I'll link to it down in the description
as well as up in the cards. If you'd
rather make a one-off contribution, you
can do that via PayPal or Venmo. I am
Drexfactor on both platforms, and I will
leave links to them down in the
description. Thank you so much in
advance. If you'd like to learn more
about another question people frequently
have about their poi, namely how to grip
them, be sure to check out this other
video that I have on that topic. Make
sure to get out and float today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon.
Thanks for watching. Take care and have
a good one. Peace.